und da sind wir auch wieder vielen dank
ihnen das Saarland es hat in dieser
Sekunde begonnen die Aktuelle Stunde es
geht um die Krise in den Kinderkliniken
und artisch göppiness der erste Redner
und der kommt aus der ins Fraktion mit
dem Ergebnis eines kaputt gesparten
Gesundheitssystems einem Ergebnis aller
Regierungen der letzten 30 Jahre und sie
wird für die Linke erforderlich weil
auch die jetzige Regierung entgegen
großer Worte nicht die richtigen
Schlüssel zieht oder so weitergehen wird
wenn wir jetzt nicht sofort handeln sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
was ist passiert bei einer Umfrage Ende
November gab jede zweite Klinik an dass
sie in den letzten 24 Stunden Kinder für
die Intensivmedizin abweisen mussten
nach dieser Kurzumfrage von divi der
deutschen interdisziplinären Vereinigung
für intensiv von Notfallmedizin hatten
von den 110 Befragten Kinderkliniken 43
kein einziges freies Bett mehr auf der
Normalstation die Umfrage war Ende
November dort standen wir am Abgrund
jetzt heute sind wir den berühmten
Schritt weiter eine Rettungsstelle
berichtete die Tage drei Kinder im Flur
vor der untersuchungszimmern die ganze
Nacht mit Sauerstoff versorgt zu haben
für so manches Kind könnte der
Wunschzettel ein Weihnachten in diesem
Jahr recht kurz ausfallen gesund werden
könnte draufstehen vielleicht auch nur
ein Bett im Krankenhaus das ist die
Situation in diesem Land sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
nun gehören zu den schwächsten unserer
Gesellschaft gemeinhin Kranke und Kinder
wenn der ehemalige Bundespräsident
Gustav Heinemann mit seinem berühmten
Zitat Recht hat dass man den Wert einer
Gesellschaft nach ihrem Umgang mit den
schwächsten Gliedern bemessen können
dann ist das bei unserem Umgang mit
kranken Kindern nun verdammt schlecht
bestellt und das perverse ist
Überlastung der Kinderkliniken ist nicht
neu es ist im Gegenteil ein traurige
Klassiker die Zeitungen könnten auch
alle Jahre wieder Titeln aber sie Titeln
im November 2019 vor Corona
Notfallpatient Kinderklinik viele
Kinderkliniken operieren jenseits ihrer
Kapazitätsgrenzen insbesondere in der
Intensivmedizin die Folgen könnten für
die Betroffenen tödlich sein oder man
hört im November 21 von einem Arzt auf
rbb manche der kleinen Patienten in der
kinderrettungsstelle müssen er bis zu
sieben Stunden warten lassen und warum
ist das so
bei den letzten 30 Jahren von allen
Bundesregierungen die Kommerzialisierung
der Krankenhäuser vorangetrieben wurde
aber in der Kinder und Jugendmedizin
lassen sich kaum profiterwirtschaften
deswegen wurden hier seit 91 fast die
Hälfte der Betten abgebaut neben dem
Betten ist auch die Anzahl der
Beschäftigten drastisch gesunken die
Patientinnen und Patienten nahmen aber
zu in den letzten 30 Jahren um 10%. und
deswegen führt jede kleine
Krankheitswelle nah an den Kollaps
und nun muss das Problem akut angegangen
werden und es muss langfristig gelöst
werden akut hebelt Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach die Pflegepersonal
Untergrenzen aus einmal mehr das
bedeutet einmal mehr werden die
Beschäftigten in den Kliniken gezwungen
mehr unserer jüngsten Patienten
Patienten gleichzeitig zu pflegen als
sie eigentlich sollten oder anders neben
den Patientinnen und ihren Eltern sind
es einmal mehr die Beschäftigten die
politische Versagen ausbauen müssen und
zwar ohne Gegenleistung und ich verrate
es Ihnen die die noch da sind Herr
Lauterbach werden kranke Kinder einmal
mehr nicht im Stich lassen aber die
Frage ist ob sie danach auch bleiben das
würde den sogenannten flexit den
Ausstieg der Pflegekräfte aus ihren Job
weiter erhöhen kurzfristig die
Beschäftigten die das von ihnen Geschäft
geschaffene Problem zu lösen haben und
langfristig sie haben versprochen die
pädiatrien bedarfsgerecht zu finanzieren
sie haben versprochen dass sie die
Fallpauschalen und den damit
einhergehenden abschaffen das ist nicht
passiert und das steht entgegen ihren
Aussagen auch nicht in jetzigen Vorhaben
sie wollen das auch gar nicht Firmen
lesen kann was bei der FDP zur Kultur
gehört hört sich bei den Grünen
folgendermaßen an man können nicht
einseitig den Anreiz rausnehmen um
Kinder zu versorgen sonst würde man ein
noch größeres Problem bekommen ich frage
sie was ist das für ein zynisches
Menschenbild das davon ausgeht dass
Ärztinnen und Ärzte und Pflegekräfte in
der Pädiatrie wirtschaftliche Anreize
bräuchten um Kinder und Jugendliche zu
versorgen kein Wunder dass die Entwürfe
aus den SPD-geführten Hause die
Fallpauschalen auch in der Pädiatrie
erhalten und eben nicht bedarfsgerecht
aus finanziert wird und akut tun sie das
genaue Gegenteil und sie lassen ab 2023
Gelder sogar nach dem Fallpauschalen
System auszahlen Kliniken die besser da
stehen erhalten auch ein größeres Stück
vom Kuchen ich fasse zusammen das
profitsystem hat im Gesundheitsbereich
nichts verloren
am deutlichsten wird dies bei der
Versorgung von Kindern sie bauen auf
kurzfristige Lösungen auf dem Rücken der
Beschäftigten aber die wissen schon dass
von ihnen keine Entschädigung keine
Wertschätzung zu erwarten ist
langfristig brechen sie trotz
mantraartiger Wiederholungen nicht mit
dem System sie wollen es nicht schauen
Sie was die divi fordert schauen Sie was
die Initiative Berliner Kinderkliniken
fordern lassen Sie uns wieder
Aufbauprogramm für die Kinder und
jugendmediziner schaffen um die Trümmer
wegzuräumen die 30 Jahre
wettbewerbsorientierung und
Fallpauschalen in der hinterlassen haben
wir brauchen keinen Kollegen ich komme
zum Schluss wir brauchen Anreize dass
die Beschäftigten zurückkommen in die
Krankenhäuser und für Kinder da zu sein
Kinder die sich nicht an Fallpauschalen
berechnen lassen sondern die einfach nur
gesund werden wollen vielen vielen Dank
ist der krankenhaus- und
pflegepolitischer Sprecher der
Linksfraktion die diese aktuelle Stunde
zur Krise in den Kinderkliniken
beantragt hat dafür hat er fünf Minuten
Zeit gehabt um diesen Antrag und den
debattenpunkt vorzustellen und viel mehr
hat auch nicht Karl Lauterbach der
Bundesgesundheitsminister der ist jetzt
dran
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren Kollegen Kollegen die
Lage in den Kinderkliniken gibt in der
Tat allen Grund zu Sorge und sie ist
wirklich eine Lage wie wir sehr in
Jahrzehnten nicht gehabt haben die
Kinder leiden unter dem RS-Virus es sind
auch andere Infektionskrankheiten zu
beobachten und das Personal fehlt es
wird seit langer Zeit am Rande
gearbeitet zumindest so seine Situation
wo wir wirklich von einer tatsächlichen
akuten Gefährdung der Versorgung der
Kinder ausgehen müssen leider ist die
Situation in den Praxen nicht besser und
in den Praxen wird auch am Limit
gearbeitet auch dort gibt es
Personalausfall und dort werden auch
zahlreiche schwere Verläufe der RS
Viruserkrankungen gesehen die eigentlich
stationär versorgt werden müssten wo es
aber kein Platz geht um somit haben wir
sofort reagiert wir haben zunächst die
personaluntergrenzen ausgesetzt nicht
weil wir das Personal noch belasten
wollen sondern wollen das Personal was
derzeit eingesetzt werden kann bei den
Kindern dort auch einsetzen und da muss
das Personal flexibel einsetzbar sein
hier geht es nicht darum wie das immer
wieder vorgetragen wird das Pflegekräfte
aus anderen Bereichen plötzlich
komplizierte Kinderpflege machen sollen
beispielsweise in der Beatmung darum
geht es nicht überhaupt nicht es geht
darum auch in der normalen Kinderklinik
werden Kinder so versorgt dass das auch
eine normale Pflegekräfte machen kann
zum Beispiel nach einem Beinbruch oder
wenn ein Blinddarm operiert wurde oder
wenn eine Mangel also Entzündung
operiert werden musste somit für diese
einfacheren Fälle da ziehen wir
Pflegekräfte daran aus anderen Bereichen
so dass die spezialpflegekräfte
eingesetzt werden können dort wo sie
genutzt werden das wird auch von den
Kliniken angenommen wir sind ja mit den
Kliniken im direkten Kontakt wir sind
mit den Kliniken im direkten Kontakt und
wir bekommen auch die Rückmeldung das
sind Maßnahmen die funktionieren aber
wir müssen mehr machen wir müssen mehr
machen und daher werden wir jetzt drei
weitere Maßnahmen ergreifen und zwar
zunächst einmal in den Praxen selbst
soll sichergestellt werden dass jeder
Leistung die dort erbracht wird auch zu
festen Preisen bezahlt wird das heißt
dort werden die Budgets ausgesetzt und
jede zusätzliche Leistung die erbracht
wird wird voll bezahlt so dass hier
nicht über Gebühr am Rande der Schöpfung
gearbeitet wird und man bekommt das auch
noch nicht einmal komplett bezahlt das
schulden wir den Praxen da ersetzen wir
die Budgetierung ab sofort für die
Kinderkliniken und für die Praxen aus
und zum zweiten ich möchte hier auch
ankündigen wir wollen noch einen Schritt
weitergehen und zwar zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt entscheiden sich zu wenige
junge Fachärzte und FachärztInnen dafür
Kinderheilkunde zu praktizieren und um
das
um das Angebot in der Kinderheilkunde in
der Praxis zu arbeiten attraktiver zu
machen werden wir eine Reform
durchsetzen wo ab jetzt der Bereich der
Kinderheilkunde auch dauerhaft von den
Budgets in der Praxis ausgeschlossen
wird somit kann dort dauerhaft so festen
Preisen praktiziert werden derjenige der
sich für die Kinderheilkunde entscheidet
weil wir haben doch dann enormen Bedarf
der nicht zu füllen ist derjenige der
sich für die Kinder hat und entscheidet
der wird von dem klassischen System der
Budgets nicht mehr erfasst und kann
allein auf der Grundlage medizinische
Überlegungen respektieren wir setzen die
Budgets in der kinderkunde in den Praxen
vollkommen und auf dauerhaft aus so dass
dieser Bereich attraktiver wird für
junge Menschen die Kindern widmen wollen
die Kinder verdienen eine budgetreifreie
Ökonomie freie Versorgung und das werden
wir sicherstellen
wir werden darüber hinaus auch mit
sofortiger Wirkung werden wir
Honorarkräfte die in Krankenhäusern
zusätzlich eingesetzt werden werden wir
über die Pflege Budgets abrechnen
kurzfristig so dass kurzfristig
zusätzliche Honorarkräfte eingesetzt
werden können auch dass diese finanziert
wird alle drei Maßnahmen werden wir
gesetzlich in der nächsten Woche
vorlegen und wir werden darüber hinaus
noch ich wir werden darüber hinaus auch
noch weitergehen wenn die Situation sich
in den Kinderkliniken nicht verbessert
dann werden wir auch so weit gehen dass
wir in den anderen Bereichen der
Erwachsenen Medizin die Eingriffe die
verschiebbar sind absetzen so dass sich
die Konzentration für die Kinder
aufbauen lässt wir haben hier folgende
Situation die Kinder haben in einer Lage
und die Erwachsenen besonders gefährdet
worden sind haben die Kinder
zurückgestanden und haben Opfer erbracht
jetzt ist die Situation umgekehrt jetzt
brauchen die Kinder unsere Hilfe daher
werden wir alles tun wir werden alles
tun um
darzustellen und dazu sind wir auch
bereit alle einkräfte die bei
Erwachsenen verschiebbar sind wo
überhaupt im Moment die Frage ist bei ob
bei der Personalnot diese Eingriffe
jetzt optimal gemacht werden können aber
wir werden alle Eingriffe zur Not
verschieben bei Erwachsenen um den
Kindern alles anzubieten was wir
anbieten können wir lassen hier kein
Kind zurück und wir werden rechtlich so
weit vorrücken dass wir den Kindern
grundsätzlich die Versorgung anbieten
können die Sie in dieser Krise benötigen
und ich möchte ich möchte hier auch noch
mal darauf hinweisen ich werde hier oft
kritisiert wenn wir uns zu wenig machen
es kennt zu spät wir arbeiten seit sechs
Monaten wir arbeiten seit sechs Monaten
arbeiten wir an einer krankenhausreform
für die Kinder und ab dem ersten 23
werden die Kinderkliniken aus dem Budget
herausragen in einem Korridor von 80 bis
100% kann eine Klinik 80% der Leistungen
bringen und bringt bekommt 100% bezahlt
das haben wir ein budgetiert ich warte
daraufhin daran haben wir sechs Monate
gearbeitet und in diesen sechs Monaten
das ist diese Krise noch nicht gab haben
wir wieder von ihnen da hätte ich es
auch nicht erwartet aber auch nicht von
ihnen einen einzigen Vorschlag gehört
der sich nur auf die Kindermedizin
bezogen hätte es gibt keinen einzigen
Vorschlag keinen einzigen Vorstand seit
sechs Monaten arbeiten wir an dieser
Reform hier sitzen die Besserwisser von
ihnen ist kein einziger Vorschlag
ich will es hier noch mal ganz deutlich
machen wir werden auch in anderen
Bereichen in diese Richtung gehen ich
habe gesagt wir sind bei der
Ökonomisierung unseres
Gesundheitssystems sind wir zu weit
gegangen wir werden da das
fahrpauschalen System überwinden am 5
Januar werden wir hier einen Klinik
Gipfel haben bei diesem klinikgipfel
werden wir uns mit Vorschlägen
beschäftigen die unsere
Expertenkommission vorgetragen hat wo es
darum geht was kann man stattdessen
machen und da werden 60% des Budgets
werden über vorhaltepauschalen und über
also die Pauschalen für Pflegekräfte
bezahlt das heißt die Krankenkasse
bekommen demnächst 60% ihres Budgets
vollkommen unabhängig von den vollkommen
unabhängig von den Fallzahlen und
diejenigen die sagen es soll für die
Fahrzeit gar nichts mehr geben die
müssen zu Ende denken ich weiß dass sie
das aufrecht aber denken Sie zu Ende
wenn wir jetzt die wenn die Fahrzeit gar
keine Rolle spielen würde dann könnten
die Kliniken das Geld mitnehmen ohne das
überhaupt behandelt wurde das wird
natürlich auch niemand somit eine solche
endökonomisierung wie wir sie jetzt
wollen Sie wissen wir haben hier
Sachverständigen die uns beraten haben
aus der Pflege aus dem Krankenhaus und
aus der Ökonomie Sachverständige die wir
gebeten haben macht kluge Vorschläge
damit wir dieses ökonomische System
überwinden das sind klugefeuchte diese
Vorschläge sollten Sie diese vorstellen
sie glauben dass ihre Vorschläge besser
sind als Sie Vorschläge Wissenschaft das
ist eine Missachtung der Wissenschaftler
glauben sie sind wir folgen der
Wissenschaft hier ist jeder jeder
nein jetzt spricht nicht mehr sie
glauben dass es besser wissen als sie
die haben
gewissenschaftler die wird die
Wissenschaftler die uns hier
unterstützen haben sich 50 Mal betroffen
haben einen 50-seitigen Report
vorgenommen den diskutieren wir mit den
Ländern und sich stehen hier hin und
sagen ja was ist denn das schon das weiß
ich doch alles besser wir glauben Sie
wer sie sind das kann nicht sagen nein
ich beziehe mich auf die Vorschläge ich
beziehe mich auf die Vorschläge die mir
hier geliefert worden sind aber ich bin
nicht der einzige Besserwisser ich komme
zum Schluss wir werden zum wir werden
darüber hinaus wir werden darüber hinaus
bei den eva-engpässen in der nächsten
Woche werden wir ebenfalls drei
Vorschläge Vorbringen wo es darum geht
dass wir die Rabattverträge ein Stück
weit adjustieren so dass diese
Lieferengpässe nicht mehr das sind
Gesetze die auch bei ihnen liegen
geblieben sind versorge das sind ja
nachholgesetze die ich jetzt in ihrer
Fraktion in ihrer Fraktion
in ihrer Fraktion bitte ich habe ich
habe ich habe sie bisher geschont aber
das wäre diese Arbeit machen weder in
der krankenhausreform noch in der Reform
der Vermeidung von Liefering dessen kann
ich hier auf Reformen zurückblicken die
sie gemacht hätten daher werden wir
diese wir werden diese Vorschläge
bringen ich bitte Sie um die
konstruktive Unterstützung und ich
möchte abschließend möchte ich mich bei
dem Personal ich möchte mich
abschließend bei den Pflegekräften und
bei den Ärztinnen und Ärzten bedanken
die diese Arbeit leisten wir werden sie
unterstützen wo auch immer wir können
darauf können Sie sich verlassen
kurz vor vier am Donnerstagnachmittag
Bundestag aktuelle Stunde am vorletzten
Sitzungstag in diesem Jahr und dann ist
er noch mal Feuer drin in dieser Debatte
in der es um die Krise in den
Kinderkliniken insbesondere auf den
Kinderstationen geht Karl Lauterbach war
das der Bundesgesundheitsminister jetzt
gibt es eine Ermahnung
Fraktionen Ergebnis
stimmt auch nicht jetzt kommt die
nächste Rednerin Simone Borchert aus der
Unionsfraktion
Bach also zu ihrer Rede muss ich mal
ganz kurz noch von meiner Rede mal
abweichen weil falls Ihnen das entgangen
ist haben Sie in den letzten Jahren die
Gesundheitspolitik mit zu verantworten
und sie haben auch die DRGs mit
eingeführt und ich finde es wirklich
ungehörig sich jetzt hier so
hinzustellen und so zu tun als ob alles
falsch und ganz schlecht ist ich bin bei
ihm dass wir vieles verändern müssen
aber hören Sie bitte auch immer so zu
tun als sind sie die letzten Jahre nicht
dabei gewesen
und nicht nur das sie haben auch
federführend die Gesundheitspolitik der
SPD vertreten so und unsere
Kinderkliniken kämpfen zurzeit mit den
schwierigsten Problemen und ich habe
nicht einen einzigen wirklichen
Lösungsansatz von Ihnen hier gehört die
kämpfen mit hohen Vorhaltekosten mit
einer schwierigen erlösssituation und
mit einem Mangel an Pflegekräften und
Ärzten und der Reformbedarf ist groß es
wird immer viel angekündigt und wirklich
seit dem halben Jahr wird die
angekündigt und wenig gemacht und da
hilft eine Expertenkommission auch nicht
wenn Sie die PS nicht endlich auf die
Straße kriegen die brauchen mehr
Effizienz und Wirtschaftlichkeit und die
Versorgung muss endlich bedarfsgerechter
werden und dabei müssen wir endlich und
schnell die Sektoren Grenzen aufbrechen
es kann doch nicht wahr sein dass sie
sich hier noch um Vergütung streiten
Ambulanz stationär Hybrid und was auch
immer das verstehen doch die Menschen
nicht während die jüngsten der
Gesellschaft darunter leiden und nicht
nur diese ich rede ja auch von besorgten
Eltern
Angehörigen wir brauchen eine
Krankenhauslandschaft die auch den
Belangen des ländlichen Raumes gerecht
wird es mangelt dabei weniger am Geld
und in Teilen auch nicht am verfügbaren
Personal wir müssen viel mehr die
Ressourcen richtig einsetzen und das ist
an der Zeit innovative Versorgungsformen
schnell an den Start zu bringen und dazu
gehören für mich auch neue
Arbeitszeitmodelle auch darüber sollten
wir ernsthaft nachdenken und das ist
genau das Gegenteil was sie gerade
machen einfach mal machen und das ist
jetzt angebracht und Sie müssen auch
endlich zur Kenntnis nehmen dass nicht
alle Bundesländer gleich sind die dünn
besiedelten Bundesländer müssen sie
strukturellen natürlich anders
aufstellen wie groß steht wie München
Hamburg Dresden diesen Umstand dürfen
wir nicht ausblenden wir versorgen sonst
wirklich wichtige Versorgungsstrukturen
in diesen Ländern wir wollen
wir wollen gleiche Lebensqualität und
Lebensverhältnisse in Stadt und Land
dann müssen wir auch über die
Mengenregelung des
gba-neu nachdenken denn so zum Beispiel
ist die frühchenintensivstation in
Neubrandenburg gefährdet und soll
geschossen werden bei Mengen nicht
eingehalten werden aber auch diese
Menschen haben einen Anspruch auf eine
gute medizinische Versorgungsqualität
hier muss nachgearbeitet werden und wenn
wir uns jetzt die Situation in den
Ländern anschauen können wir feststellen
die Stationen sind voll es fehlen Betten
und die Eltern müssen mit ihren Kindern
lange in den Notaufnahmen warten
natürlich ist das ein unhaltbarer
Zustand und ich kann wirklich alle
Eltern verstehen sie sich hier große
Sorgen machen und wir stehen erst am
Anfang der Saison wo die ganzen
Erkältungskrankheiten kommen werden aber
damit die Notaufnahme nicht so
überlastet sind sollten wir über den
ganzen Prozess und vor allem vom Anfang
an denken das heißt wir müssen auch
ärztlichen und medizinischen
Bereitschaftsdienst neu aufstellen wir
sollten die Behandlung die Telemedizin
stärker forcieren und hier eine bessere
Vergütung möglich machen damit eben
nicht alle in die Notaufnahme kommen
sondern schon durch den ärztlichen
Bereitschaftsdienst gut und qualitativ
versorgt werden und das heißt für mich
wirklich den Prozess ganz zu denken wir
müssen auch die Planungsbereiche der
Ärztin den Fokus nehmen damit sie dem
doch nicht mehr sich alle in den Städten
ansiedeln sondern auch im ländlichen
Bereich
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
aber es gibt kein Grund Panik zu machen
aus den Kliniken aus meinem Bereich
wurde mir bestätigt ja wir sind zwar im
krisenmodus aber die Versorgung von dem
Patienten ist gewährleistet jetzt ist es
nur wesentlich dass zügig gehandelt wird
und abschließend möchte ich noch sagen
die cdu/csu hat bereits am Anfang des
Jahres zwei gute Anträge eingebracht die
wurden allesamt von ihnen abgelehnt das
sind die Bonusregelungen für die
Pflegekräfte die Sie vergessen haben
und wir hatten auch einen Antrag schon
eingereicht um Krankenhäuser und
Pflegeeinrichtungen finanziell zu
unterstützen und sie haben damit
wertvolle Zeit vergoldet damit diese
Leistungserbringer wirklich
hochqualitative Versorgung gewährleisten
können also Herr Minister es wird
höchste Zeit dass sie ins Tun kommen
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
für die Unionsfraktion sitzt sie im
Gesundheitsausschuss und die Aktuelle
Stunde die auf Antrag der Linksfraktion
stattfindet wird fortgesetzt mit der
Parteivorsitzenden von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Ricarda lang
Geehrten liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Lage all den Kinderkliniken ist
ernst wir sehen Kinder Eltern die
teilweise keinen Platz mehr finden wir
sehen ÄrztInnen und Pflegekräfte die
vollkommen überlastet sind und wir sehen
viele Menschen die schon in den letzten
Jahren unfassbares geleistet haben
diesen Gesundheitssystem und jetzt
wirklich auf dem Zahnfleisch gehen und
der gute grund dafür ist eine
Infektionswelle die unser Land im Moment
hart trifft aber müssen auch ehrlich
sein das trifft auf ein
Gesundheitssystem das in den letzten
Jahrzehnten und vor allem letzten 16
Jahren Missmanagement und falsche
Weichenstellungen erlebt hat aber hier
vielleicht Einsatz zu Ihnen Frau
Borchert ich finde für die partielle
Amnesie zu vergessen werden in den
letzten 16 Jahren mitregiert hat und
werden in den letzten Jahren das
Gesundheitsministerium gestellt hat
dafür ist vor allem ihre Fraktion
bekannt
ich möchte diese Chance einmal nutzen um
vor allem Danke zu sagen danke an die
vielen Menschen in den Arztpraxen an die
vielen Menschen in den Kinderkliniken an
die vielen Pflegekräfte die trotz dieser
oberwidrigen Umstände die trotz dieser
harten Zeit alles tun um die jüngsten
und um die verwundbarsten unserer
Gesellschaft zu schützen
nee ich nahmlich ich komme jetzt zu den
Maßnahmen die diese Regierung auf den
Weg gebracht hat vermutlich auch weil
ihre Fraktion nicht Teil davon ist wenn
ja danke bleibt noch nicht stehen
sondern diese dank wäre natürlich
zynisch wenn wir als Politikerin dort
stehen bleiben würden sondern wir müssen
ganz akut handeln um die Menschen in
Kliniken um die Menschen Arztpraxen zu
unterstützen und dafür haben wir einiges
auf den Weg gebracht innerhalb der
letzten Monate mehr finanzielle
Unterstützung deine
finanzierungsgarantie für Kinderkliniken
die PPR 2.0 eine langjährige Forderung
gerade von Pflegekräften von
pflegegewerkschaften die Ausweitung der
Kinderkrankheiten Tage und heute erst
haben wir hier beschlossen die Strom und
gaspreisbremse die auch für die Kliniken
greifen wird das Kliniken in dieser
harten Zeit unterstützt werden hier zu
behaupten nichts wäre passiert gerade
nach ihrem 16 Jahren das ist einfach
falsch an der Realität vorbei und
zynisch
zweitens geht es darum akute Maßnahmen
auf den Weg zu bringen um jetzt ganz
konkret die Kinderkliniken zu
unterstützen eine Koordination zwischen
Kliniken wie Personal gut verteilt
werden kann und ja auch die Verteilung
von Personal in die Kinderkliniken in
die Kinderstation und da geht es nicht
darum dass die dort konkret die
Kinderpflege übernehmen Kinder sind
nicht einfach nur kleine Erwachsene und
das wäre überhaupt nicht möglich sondern
es geht darum bei
organisatorischen bei Zusatzarbeiten zu
unterstützen so dass die Kinder
Pflegenden tatsächlich ihre Arbeit
nachgehen können das ist eine richtige
Weichenstellung die wir jetzt auf den
Weg bringen dass es notwendig und ich
sage ja auch explizit den Vorschlag von
Karl Lauterbach die entitätsierung bei
den Kinderarztpraxen das finden wir als
Bündnis 90 die Grünen richtig und
unterstützen diesen Vorstoß sehr sehr
gerne
und trotzdem ist klar das sind
grießmaßnahmen und das sind keine
Maßnahmen die dauerhaft gelten können
das jetzt innerhalb von verschiedenen
Pflegebereichen Leute umverteilt werden
müssen das ist ein riesengroßes Problem
und das ist keine Lösung für die Zukunft
wir müssen nicht nur an Pflaster auf die
Wunde Gräben sondern müssen auch dafür
sorgen dass diese Wunde endlich geheilt
wird und darum geht es jetzt dort dran
zu gehen indem wir drei Dinge tun
erstens nehmen wir die
Professionalisierung der Pflege auf den
Weg bringen wenn wir andere Länder
schauen auch das was Pflegekräfte
leisten können was sie leisten dürfen
stärker zu nutzen denn Pflegekräfte sind
nichts anderes als die Experten für die
Zukunft unseres Gesundheitswesens
zweitens indem wir die Kinderpflege und
auch die Kindermedizin ganz explizit
Stärken einige Vorschläge wurden hier
gerade schon genannt und indem wir auch
die Kinder Lobby stärker wahrnehmen denn
das stimmt in den letzten Jahren hat die
ehrlich gesagt an vielen Stellen gefehlt
und vor allem haben oft die kleinen am
stärksten zurückgesteckt und das muss
ich jetzt ändern
und
[Applaus]
Heizsystems dass sie in den letzten
Jahrzehnten geprägt hat zurückdrängt
denn es stimmt tatsächlich dass immer
wieder die falschen Weichenstellungen
gestellt werden und das ist jetzt darum
geht die Krankenhausplanung denn zu
Finanzierung gehört auch Planung und die
Krankenhausfinanzierung neu aufzustellen
denn hier wurde vorher gesagt von einem
Vorredner von den Linken wir hätten
unsere Gesundheitssystem kaputt gespart
das stimmt einfach nicht Deutschland
gibt im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern
nicht wenig Geld für Gesundheit aus aber
es wird falsch verteilt und dann diese
Verteilung werden wir als Ampel jetzt
endlich dran gehen dass wir lieben gute
Vorschläge vor wir werden der Koalition
noch einige Debatten dazu führen haben
aber für mich ist ganz klar in Zukunft
muss das bezahlt werden was gebraucht
wird und nicht das womit der
größtmögliche Profit gemacht werden kann
wir müssen die starre Trennung zwischen
ambulant und stationär endlich
überwindene wir müssen Prävention viel
mehr abbilden
in der klinikfinanzierung und ja das
System der reinen Fallpauschalen muss
endlich Geschichte werden vielen Dank
Ricarda langen am Ende noch mal mit
Bezügen zu Vorhaben die der
Bundesgesundheitsminister schon
eingeleitet hat bezüglich der
sogenannten fall-pauschalen nächster
Redner ist Martin sicher dass der
afd-fraktion da ist ja
gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wie man Stimmung gegen Kinder in den
vergangenen drei Jahren gemacht hat war
absolut unsäglich zum Beispiel
Böhmermann im ZDF von diesem Jahr ich
zitiere um sie herum lauern zur Zeit
gefährliche kleine Mikroorganismen die
einen krank machen wollen Kinder Kinder
sind zurzeit gemeingefährlich was Ratten
in der pestwaren sind Kinder zur Zeit
für Kurve 19 wird Tiere Kinder sind noch
schlimmer als alle Hutträger in der
sächsischen Fußgängerzone weil die
Handeln unverantwortlich und sehen dabei
so niedlich aus
für solch eine unsägliche Verbreitung
von Hass und Hetze gegenüber den
Schwächsten der Gesellschaft gab es
keine Konsequenzen der Böhmermann
arbeitet weiterhin im ZDF und er hält
auf Kosten der
beitragsgehalt sie alle machen sich
völlig lächerlich wenn Sie die größten
Hetzer im ZDF weiter hetzen lassen aber
auf der anderen Seite Zensur bei Twitter
und anderen Medien fordern
die Intensivstationen der Kinderkliniken
sind randvoll weil Kindern durch Maske
und Abstand die notwendigen Antikörper
fehlen Abstand und Maske
des Immunsystem der Bevölkerung laut dem
Münchner Immunologen Peter Schleicher
ist die corona-politik für die Krise in
den Kinderkliniken verantwortlich ich
zitiere Kinder brauchen bis zu 16
Effekte im Jahr damit sie überhaupt erst
ein intaktes Immunsystem aufbauen können
deshalb werden heute so viele Kinder
schwer krank als Vater von zwei kleinen
Kindern finde ich es beängstigend dass
jetzt schon wieder von Lauterbach wieder
und anderen Appelle zum Masken tragen
kommen lass die Kinder endlich die
notwendigen Infekte durchmachen damit
sie ein gutes Immunsystem bekommen und
auch als Erwachsene später gut geschützt
sind
kinderärztepräsident Fischbach findet
dazu die richtigen Worte ich zitiere der
Schrei nach Masken ist der übliche
Reflex der Politik dabei ist die
maskenpflicht der zurückliegenden zwei
Jahre ja ein wichtiger Grund für die
aktuelle Krise man kann übrigens an
dieser Thematik wunderbar sehen wie die
sogenannten faktenchecker von Korrektiv
keine faktenchecken sondern Fake News
verbreiten die haben nämlich am 28 Mai
2020 einen Artikel veröffentlicht unter
dem Titel nein Masken Schwächen nicht
das Immunsystem am Ende des Beitrags
stand dann ich zitiere Fazit die
Behauptung dass durch Masken das
Immunsystem geschwächt werden ist falsch
statt seriösem faktencheckt die
Verbreitung von Fake News aber das sind
wir von den sogenannten faktencheckern
ja gewohnt
wir von der AFD waren übrigens schon
2020 weiter als sie es heute sind wir
haben schon vor zwei Jahren gefordert
Kinder von sämtlichen Masken und
Abstandsregeln auszunehmen sie alle
haben dagegen gestimmt und Kinder zum
Maske Desinfektion und Abstand gezwungen
sie alle sind daran schuld dass aktuell
so viele Kinder schwer erkranken
wir von der AFD sind diejenigen denen es
von Anfang an darum ging den Menschen
ein Leben in Gesundheit und Freiheit zu
ermöglichen ihnen ging es darum Panik zu
verbreiten und da Kinder als schwächste
der Gesellschaft sich am wenigsten
wehren konnten würden sie von ihnen am
stärksten gemobbt übrigens haben wir von
der AFD in den letzten drei Jahren nicht
nur immer wieder Anträge gestellten
Masken und Abstandsregeln zu unterlassen
sondern auch mehrfach darauf hingewiesen
dass es völlig falsch ist die Zahl der
Intensivbetten in Corona Zeiten zu
reduzieren der Gesundheitsminister
hingegen plant den medizinischen
Kahlschlag zitiere Karl Lauterbach jeder
weiß dass wir in Deutschland mindestens
jede dritte eigentlich jede zweite
Klinik schließen sollten nein Herr
Lauterbach die jetzige Krise zeigt uns
dass wir um jedes Krankenhaus dass wir
haben heilfroh sein können
der Unterschied zwischen Karl Lauterbach
und der AFD ist dass das was Karl
Lauterbach fordert sich ständig als
fatal für die Menschen erweist während
der Forderungen der AFD immer wieder mit
der Zeit von den anderen Parteien
übernommen werden weil sie schlicht
richtig und wichtig sind
insofern wundert uns von der AFD nicht
dass die Linken nun die Forderung der
AFD nach Abschaffung des
fallpauschalensystems übernehmen aber
wir wundern uns ehrlich gesagt schon ein
bisschen warum sie vor nicht mal zwei
Monaten noch unseren Antrag der genau
das forderte hier im Bundestag abgelehnt
haben und sie nun heute das Thema als so
wichtig sehen dass Sie dazu eine
Aktuelle Stunde einberufen sollten Sie
einen vernünftigen Antrag stellen das
Fallpauschalensystem abzuschaffen werden
wir dem zustimmen weil es uns im
Gegensatz zu ihnen nicht darum geht wer
einen Antrag stellt sondern was das
Beste für die Bürger ist
meine Damen und Herren wir alle müssen
aus der jetzigen Situation lernen dass
man nie wieder Kinder zum Maske und
Abstand nötigen sollte weil wir damit
den Kindern massiven Schaden zufügen
kommt
diese möglicherweise ein ganzes Leben
lang leiden müssen
[Applaus]
nächster Redner ist für die FDP-Fraktion
Professor Dr Andrew Ullmann
und Andrew Uhlmann ist
gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher in der
FDP-Fraktion
sehr verehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich denke nach so eine Rede muss man
erstmal Danke sagen danke den Menschen
die heute Kinder helfen gesund zu werden
danke für die bisher geleistete
bisher Geleistete und auch schon mal im
voraus Danke zu sagen was noch
bevorsteht dann ist es sehr bedauerlich
dass wir hier noch nicht am Ende unserer
Infektionsfälle in diesem Winter stehen
es steht uns auch einiges bevor und wir
stehen auf ihrer Seite kann ich an
dieser Stelle rufen von Seiten der Ampel
den kinderklinikern den niedergelassenen
Kollegen Kollegen die jetzt hier
versucht hier das Gesundheitssystem auch
weg zu halten
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen ist
allerdings bedauerlich dass sie als
Linke diese schreckliche Situation
nutzen um das Thema unterkomplex
darzustellen denn ihre antiökonomische
Propaganda zeigt dass sie die komplexe
Problemlage gar nicht erkannt haben
obwohl jeder weiß dass wir eines der
teuersten Systeme der Welt haben alles
was Ihnen zum Thema einfällt ist relativ
einfach das Ende der Fallpauschalen zu
schreien und straßmedizin zu fordern sie
glauben doch nicht allen Ernstes dass
wenn wir ein Gesundheitssystem haben wir
da ehemaligen DDR mit der jetzigen
belassen hätte besser umgehen können
also letztendlich sie müssen ja selber
wissen sie sind ja schon Freunde mit der
AFD wie man mitgekriegt hat
aber ich will damit sagen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das natürlich
das System keine Fehler hat oder durch
die Fehlverteilung und Anreize auch
existieren sie sind offensichtlich
durchsehe positiv in die Zukunft dass
wir es schaffen werden die in 20 Jahren
die Bauunion aufgestaut und
strukturellen Defizite im
Gesundheitswesen abzubauen da zählt auch
und vor allem die Kinder und
Jugendmedizin und es ist sehr
bemerkenswert heute die general Amnesie
der Union zuzuhören
wir die Ampelkoalition haben mit der
Schaffung von tagesbehandlung in
Krankenhäusern und sektorgleichen
Vergütung eine verbesserte Situation
geschaffen um sowohl die stationäre als
auch ambulante Versorgung zu
gewährleisten
zusätzlich haben wir die finanziellen
Mittel für die akute Situation von rund
760 Millionen Euro für die kommenden
zwei Jahre für die stationäre Pädiatrie
und Geburtshilfe zur Verfügung gestellt
dazu kommen
sie verstehen es nicht auch keinen Sinn
das jetzt zu erklären es geht meine Zeit
vorbei doch die ist absolut dazu kommen
noch die Milliarden für die
Energiekosten die die Kliniken entlasten
das sind Mittel die akut helfen weil sie
Planungssicherheit geben dazu kommt dass
wir auf dem Weg des gesamte System
nachhaltig zu reformieren für die
stationäre Versorgung von Kindern und
Jugendlichen wird das vor der Pandemie
im Jahre 2019 erbrachte erlösvolumen
weitgehend garantiert um das
tatsächliche Druck der existiert auch
abzubauen mögliche viel Anreize werden
auch verhindert das erst ein Teil der
überfällige Strukturreform meine Damen
und Herren und wer hat das gemacht die
Ampel hat nämlich gemacht
und dann vergessen Sie liebe linke und
die hören ja schon gar nicht mehr zu
ganz so gar die Niedergelassenen Kinder
und jugendärztin und Ärzte denn die
ambulanten Kinder und
jugendmedizinerinnen und Mediziner
behandeln nämlich 85 bis 90 Prozent der
Kranken diese Arbeit nämlich unabhängig
von Fallpauschalen und sind doch ebenso
belastet wie die stationäre Einrichtung
hier ist der größte Fehler natürlich die
Budgetierung aber diese werden wir
abschaffen damit endlich jede Leistung
bezahlt wird das haben wir im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart und das
meine Damen und Herren liebe linke das
ist Fortschritt und was sie machen ist
Rückschritt
zurzeit sehen wir ein extreme Prävalenz
von respiratorischen Erkrankungen in
ganz Deutschland aber dieses Phänomen
ist halt leider weltweit sichtbar und
ganz egal welches Gesundheitssystem
betroffen ist dieser Zustand bringt das
bringt dieses Thema an den Rand der
Belastung und manchmal darüber hinaus
aber was können wir nun tun um den Druck
zu minimieren um zu helfen um diese
schreckliche aber hoffentlich kurze
Zeitspanne zu überwinden wir können wir
es die Linke möchte einfach die
fallpauschalsysteme abschaffen damit
wäre keinem einzigen Kind geholfen
vielleicht ein bisschen Chaos und noch
mehr Leid verursachen
prinzipiell finde ich in der jetzigen
Situation jede Maßnahme richtig die
pragmatisch und ölokratisch Flexibilität
schafft und da handelt der Bundes-
politisch machen wir alles was sinnvolle
ist jetzt möglich aber wir sind auch auf
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger unseres
Landes angewiesen denn Gesundheit kann
und da niemals staatlich ostritiert
werden und es immer auch auf die
Vernunft und das und die
Gesundheitskompetenz der Bevölkerung
angewiesen versuchen Sie alle die
Ausbreitung des Virus zu minimieren das
RKI gibt entsprechende alltagstaugliche
Empfehlungen kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss der Kollege sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren die jetzige Situation ist
eine Folge der verfehlten
Gesundheitspolitik der letzten Jahre in
den Ländern und im Bund da können wir
als volksschutzkoalition diesen
kommunikativen Fehler nicht innerhalb
weniger Wochen auf dem Weg aus dem Weg
räumen aber wir werden die Fehler Stück
für Stück und vor allem nachhaltig
beseitigen danke schön
Ullmann war das aus der FDP-Fraktion
gesundheitspolitischer Sprecher dort der
Bundestag diskutiert an diesem
Donnerstagnachmittag über die Krise in
den Kinderkliniken und dazu jetzt Heidi
Reicheneck sie aus der Linksfraktion und
sie ist auch Mitglied in der
Kinderkommission
das ein Kind stirbt
weil das sagte die Chefärztin der Kinder
und Jugendmedizin am St Josef
Krankenhaus hier in Berlin diese Woche
verzweifelte Eltern müssen mit ihren
kranken Kindern stundenlang in der
Notaufnahme warten die Kinder haben
Schmerzen leiden und ob sie überhaupt
behandelt werden können das weiß
niemanden die Betten sind knapp Personal
überlastet Operation werden verschoben
das geht so weit dass dem Vater eines
jungen Mädchens mit gebrochenem Arm
gesagt wird notfalls müsste der anderen
dann eben noch mal gebrochen werden um
ihn später richtig zu behandeln wann
auch immer später ist denn es werden
täglich hunderte Operation verschoben
die irgendwann nachgeholt werden sollen
das ist die Realität und die frage sie
was ist das für eine Gesellschaft die so
mit kranken Kindern umgeht während die
Versorgung der kleinsten nicht mehr
sichergestellt ist machen private
Klinikbetreiber auf Kosten unsere
Gesundheit hunderte Millionen gewinnen
ja wir pumpen Geld ins Gesundheitssystem
und zwar auf die konnten der
Großkonzerne herzlichen Dank dafür wie
pervers ist das
und sie Herr Lauterbach die sagen wir
werden alles tun das stimmt einfach
nicht sie unterwerfen die Gesundheit
weiter den Marktmechanismus und sie
haben wirklich die Hotbar uns zu fragen
wer wir glauben wer wir sind weil wir
ein Gesundheitssystem wollen dass ich
nicht an Profiten sondern obwohl der
Menschen orientiert ich sage Ihnen wer
wir sind wir sind die die sich nicht
kaufen lassen
aktuell
aktuell auf den Eltern verzweifelt von
Apotheken zur Apotheke weil es kein
Fiebersaft mehr gibt keine Antibiotika
sie wenden sich an bekannte sogar an
Fremde und versuchen im Ausland an diese
Medikamente anzukommen das alles
passiert vor unseren Augen und ja Herr
Minister Lauterbach übrigens für sie ist
das auch alles auf Twitter nachzulesen
das scheint ja der einzige Weg zu sein
auf dem man mit ihm kommunizieren kann
schauen Sie mal unter dem Hashtag
Kindheit brennt da können Sie einiges
lernen
und der medikamentenmangel der führt
doch direkt in einen Teufelskreis wo
müssen denn fiebernde Kinder hin wenn es
keine Medizin mehr gibt na genau in die
Notaufnahme weil die Eltern nicht mehr
wissen was sie noch machen sollen und
dort muss das vollkommen überlastete
Personal jetzt auch noch das
Marktversagen bei den Medikamenten
auffangen wo sind die Krisengipfel und
sofort Pakete zur Entlastung der
Kinderkliniken wo ist der
notfallbeschaffungsplan für
kindermedikamente jede zweite Klinik
musste Kinder abweisen die ein
intensivbild brauchten auf den Stationen
müssen vollkommen überlaste Pflegekräfte
jetzt zusätzlich kindervorsorgen obwohl
sie dafür gar nicht ausgebildet sind
aber dahin versetzt worden sind und die
haben panische Angst Fehler zu machen
erste Kinderkliniken starten Aufrufe an
die Bevölkerung bei der Versorgung von
Kindern auszuhelfen medizinische
Kenntnisse nicht erforderlich was wollen
Sie Unternehmen das krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz ist eine Fahrt und was
sie weiterhin nicht haben ist ein Plan
zur Fachkräftegewinnung ein Plan um die
Ausbildung endlich so zu gestalten dass
sich junge Menschen diese Ausbildung
überhaupt leisten können einen Plan um
die die ihren Job aufgegeben haben
zurückzuholen
300.000 Pflegekräfte haben angegeben in
den alten Job zurückzukehren wenn sich
die Bedingungen verbessern Fachkräfte
die wir dringend auch auf den
Kinderstationen brauchen Gesundheit ist
keine x-beliebige Ware mit der
Großkonzerne und Aktionär einen Kasse
machen sollen
Gesundheitsversorgung ist ein
Menschenrecht nicht spekulations-
Lauterbach übrigens schön dass sie jetzt
zum ersten Mal eine Revolution im
Gesundheitssystem ankündigen weil sie
jetzt endlich auch verstanden haben dass
es ein Zitat Ungleichgewicht zwischen
Gesundheit und Ökonomie gibt aber sie
haben doch damals das brandgefährliche
System der Fallpauschalen mit
vorangetrieben und damit dafür gesorgt
dass Krankenhäuser ihre Abteilungen nach
Rentabilität aussortiert haben und oh
Wunder Kinderkliniken lohnt sich einfach
nicht und jetzt sagen Sie ja selbst das
60% der Kinderkliniken kurz vor dem
finanziellen Ruin stehen wer glaubt da
noch an den selbstlernten
Revolutionsführer Lauterbach wir trauen
die nicht mal mehr eine Förmchen hinzu
das Profit über allem steht schade der
großen Mehrheit unserer Gesellschaft vor
allem Kindern und Jugendlichen aber hey
wen interessieren schon während sie ja
auch nur beachtet wenn es darum gingen
sie zu betreuen damit die Eltern weiter
arbeiten gehen können das kann ich auch
in meiner Erfahrung der Jugendhilfe
ziemlich deutlich erzählen gegen die
psychischen und physischen Auswirkungen
der Krisen gibt es weiterhin nichts
Kinder und Jugendliche haben den letzten
Jahren auch so viel verzichtet
Freundinnen nicht getroffen Klassenfahrt
nicht mitgemacht Chaos im Kitas und
Schulen die Angst liebe Menschen
anzustecken und trotzdem haben die
Kinder und Jugendlichen ohne zu meckern
Masken getragen und Tests gemacht im
Gegensatz zu manchen Erwachsenen
übrigens nicht nur die Kliniken sind am
Limit die Kitas und Schulen stehen vor
dem Kollaps die Jugendhilfe und die
therapeutische Betreuung brechen
zusammen und wen trifft das besonders
hat natürlich die Kinder und
Jugendlichen die als armen Familien
kommen sie werden öfter und länger krank
sind stärker von psychischen
Erkrankungen betroffen sie leiden unter
Zukunft Ängsten und das ja leider auch
zu Recht denn sie sind im Bildungssystem
massiv benachteiligt haben kaum Chancen
ihre Lebensumstände zu verbessern können
weniger in der Gesellschaft teilhaben zu
all diesen Problemen liegen zahlreiche
Studien vor es geht nicht nur um die
Kinderkliniken es geht um alle Bereiche
für Kinder und Jugendliche ja Kindheit
brennt und ihre bisherigen Löschversuche
sind kläglich gescheitert eine echte
Revolution muss mit der Marktlogik
brechen Kinder müssen sich nicht rechnen
[Applaus]
Linksfraktion
Mitglied in der Kinderkommission ist sie
hier im Deutschen Bundestag und hat sich
geäußert zur Krise in den Kinderkliniken
und da insbesondere zu den ökonomischen
Aspekten die ja im Moment hier mehr als
umstritten sehen Heike Behrens ist die
nächste Rednerin gesundheitspolitische
Sprecherin der SPD-Fraktion
en liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
mit platter kampfretorik die Situation
zu dramatisieren hilft weder den Kindern
und Familien noch den Ärztinnen und
Ärzten oder den Pflegekräfte
ja es ist richtig die Situation auf
vielen Kinderstationen ist dieser Tage
höchst angespannt die Welle der
Atemwegsinfektion trifft auf einen
Versorgungssystem das nach fast drei
Jahren Pandemie erschöpft ist die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter in den
Kliniken stehen unter höchstspannung die
Hausarztpraxen und die Kinder und
jugendärzte werden überrannt Familien
stehen erneut unter Druck durch die oft
lang anhaltenden
rsv-infektionen und haben Sorge im
Notfall nicht schnell ärztlichen Rat zu
bekommen das Kinder und Jugendliche in
manchen Regionen keine Aufnahme finden
wenn sie eigentlich in der Klinik
versorgt werden müssten verunsichert
viele Familien und macht den dringenden
Handlungsbedarf deutlich Krankenhäuser
dürfen finanziell nicht auf Kante genäht
sein krankenhäuser müssen Kapazitäten
vorhalten können für solche Spitzen
Krankenhäuser und ganz ganz speziell
Kinderkliniken müssen
personell gut ausgestattet sein
dieser Handlungsbedarf ist erkannt es
wurden bereits
wichtigen
neu gestimmt der Krankenhausfinanzierung
ist angestoßen worden durch unseren
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach und
2019 haben wir als SPD bereits in der
vorgängerkoalition daran will ich sie
erinnern hier drüben das pflegebudget
eingeführt und das heißt seit zwei
Jahren werden alle Personalkosten für
die Pflege in vollem Umfang außerhalb
der Fallpauschalen vergütet
Krankenhausträger können theoretisch
jede Pflegekraft einstellen die Sie
finden können und bekommen sie auch
refinanziert doch woher kommen die Ärzte
und fachpflegepersonen die wir jetzt
dringend benötigen in allen Bereichen
der Pflege haben wir einen akuten
Personalmangel Krankenhäuser wie die
Kinderklinik ST Luise in Paderborn
helfen sich gerade indem sie einen
Appell gestartet haben sie sprechen
urständler Pflegekräfte die den Beruf
verlassen haben Studierende und andere
an und sollten Sie in dieser
angespannten Situation mitzuhelfen und
überraschenderweise sie finden Resonanz
das hilft kurzfristig ist auf Dauer aber
natürlich keine Lösung aber ein
wichtiger Hinweis worauf es ankommt wir
müssen dafür sorgen die
Arbeitsbedingungen in der Pflege wieder
so attraktiv zu machen dass niemand mehr
diesen für unsere Gesellschaft so
wertvollen Beruf verlässt
[Applaus]
wir brauchen gute Tarife und moderne
Arbeitszeitgestaltung die jungen
Menschen eine Perspektive bietet und die
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf
ermöglicht und wir brauchen eine
gesellschaftliche Wertschätzung dieser
Arbeit die weit übers applaudieren
hinausgeht
damit die Arbeitsbedingungen nachhaltig
besser werden haben wir mit dem
Krankenhaus
pflegeentlastungsgesetz die Einführung
einer verbindlichen
pflegepersonalbemessung beschlossen wir
bringen ein Instrument auf den Weg das
von den Pflegefachpersonen selbst
entwickelt und umgesetzt wird und diese
Maßnahme wird langfristig eine große
Wirkung entfalten davon sind auch die
Gewerkschaft Verdi und der Deutsche
Pflegerat überzeugt
um jetzt schnell Entlastung auf den
Kinderstationen zu schaffen nehmen wir
die Pädiatrie nun aus den Fallpauschalen
den sogenannten diagees heraus und für
die nächsten zwei Jahre bekommen die
Kinderkliniken zusätzlich jährlich 300
Millionen Euro damit steigen wir in eine
neue finanzierungslogik ein denn
Vorhaltekosten müssen bezahlt werden die
Krankenhäuser bekommen eine feste
Grundfinanzierung egal wie viele
Behandlungen Sie durchführen
wir können uns dann auch in solchen
zugespitzen Situationen wie jetzt darauf
verlassen dass die Kapazitäten reichen
werden der Einstieg in eine große
krankenhausreform die unser Minister
Karl Lauterbach in dieser
Legislaturperiode auf den Weg gebracht
hat dieser Einstieg ist geschafft liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir drehen mit
der
krankenhausreform ich denke ein ganz
großes Rad und jetzt kommt es darauf an
dass alle Beteiligten mitziehen
insbesondere die Länder und da schaue
ich ganz bewusst rüber zur cdu/csu denn
da können Sie Ihren Lippenbekenntnissen
Taten folgen lassen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
Heike Behrens war dass die
gesundheitspolitische Sprecherin der
SPD-Fraktion der Bundestag diskutiert
auf Antrag der Linksfraktion in einer
aktuellen Stunde über die Krise in den
Kinderkliniken und jetzt kommen zwei
Redner hintereinander die noch ein
bisschen besser Bescheid wissen über die
Lage in Kinderkliniken Emmi Zollner z.B
ist dexaminierte Gesundheits- und
Krankenpflegerin
fährt mit dieser aktuellen Stunde
erreicht das Minister Lauterbach nicht
bei Markus landsmaßnahmen verkündet hat
sondern hier im Deutschen Bundestag und
also deswegen ich würde es gerne mal
auseinandernehmen er hat ja jetzt die
endbudgetierung für die Kinderarztpraxen
beschlossen das ist ein guter ein
wichtiger Schritt meine Bitte wer dem
Antrag der Union zuzustimmen wir hatten
das eingebracht zum Thema der
Medizinischen Fachangestellten denn ich
gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel aus meiner
Heimat dort musste eine kinderarztklinik
schließen weil eben die medizinischen
Fachangestellten gefehlt haben und
deswegen brauchen wir wenn wir wirklich
nachhaltig denken und es wird immer
Wellen geben die es jetzt extrem das
wusste auch jeder nach der
corona-pandemie wo Abstandsregelung
Masken das jetzt Infektionen nachgeholt
werden ja natürlich was denn sonst aber
da müssen wir hingehen und deswegen
herzliche Einladung unserem Antrag
zuzustimmen dass eben die MFA eine
Reform in der Ausbildung bekommen dafür
brauchen wir dringend einen Bund
ländergipfel denn das beste die beste
Finanzierung nützt eben am Ende nichts
auch in den Arztpraxen wenn dann die
medizinischen Fachangestellten fehlen
sie haben angekündigt dass die
Untergrenzen es ist ja der Fall eben
ausgesetzt werden und auch da wissen wir
natürlich was der Hintergrund ist und es
ist natürlich vor allem deshalb eben das
keine Strafzahlungen gezahlt werden
müssen in den Krankenhäusern und ich
glaube das ist das Mindeste was wir in
dem Bereich tun können aber auch das ist
eben nur eine kleine Maßnahme die jetzt
kurzfristig wirken kann die aber keine
lange Lösung bringt und deswegen müssen
wir dringend auch in der sie haben es
jetzt auch mit verschiedenen Maßnahmen
im Jahr versucht zu beweisen die 300
Millionen Euro die sie zur Verfügung
stellen eben für die Kinderkliniken da
sehen wir aber das ist halt eben nur so
halb ernst meinen denn ein Viertel der
Gelder kommt eben nicht bei den
Kinderkliniken an sondern die kommt in
der allgemeinen Krankenhausfinanzierung
an und es somit nicht zielgerichtet
deswegen stimmt es nicht ganz und auch
was die Hebammen beispielsweise angeht
haben sie eben in dieser gerade eben
leider in den letzten Monaten erstmal
die Hebammen aus den Budgets
rausgestrichen und sie dann wieder und
wir haben es mühevoll wieder
reingekämpft wieder eben zur Verfügung
zu stellen und jetzt wird eben jetzt
kommt die die Nagelprobe da bitte ich
Sie darum wir haben ja noch das ganz
große Thema der Perinatalzentren wir
haben 30 Kliniken die in unserem Land
auf kurz davor stehen dass sie
geschlossen werden und wenn ich jetzt
als Erkenntnis habe dass eben
Pflegekräfte sich in einem Radius von 20
Kilometern bewegen und unsere Antwort
ist weiterhin 30 Kliniken zu schließen
dann bedeutet es im Umkehrschluss dass
diese Pflegekräfte Fachpflegekräfte sie
eben nicht zwingender Zentralisierung
folgen sondern dass die wahrscheinlich
sich vor Ort eine Arbeitsstelle die auf
reichlich vorhanden ist suchen werden
und deshalb fordere Sie ganz konkret aus
und sind sehr schade dass sie heute das
nicht angekündigt haben dass gerade die
Perinatalzentren wo Neonatologie und so
weiter verordnet ist das gerade die
weiterhin in der Bedrohung stehen
geschlossen zu werden und ich fördere
sie auf und er führen Sie mit uns dazu
diese Debatte
bei der Ausbildung das ist das nächste
dass die generalistik die müssen wir
natürlich zurück in den Deutschen
Bundestag holen wir müssen hier darüber
sprechen wie geht es mit der
generalistik weiter und lieber Herr
Lauterbach ich kann mich noch gut daran
erinnern sie haben federführend mit
einem Kollegen von der Union die
generalistik mitverhandelt bis zum
Schluss und ich habe ihnen immer wieder
gesagt die Kinder Krankenpflege muss
anders behandelt werden Kinder sind eben
keine kleinen Erwachsenen und es sehen
wir eben an den Ausbildungszahlen wir
sehen dass eben auch Leute die
Ausbildung nicht machen weil sie eben
sagen nein ich kann mir es nicht
vorstellen in der Erwachsenen
Krankenpflege und deswegen müssen wir
uns das noch mal anschauen und wenn ich
eben sehe dort wo Ausbildung stattfindet
ist weniger Fachkräftemangel aber in
Berlin gibt es meiner Kenntnis nach
nicht mal eine Ausbildungstelle in der
generalistik die die Vertiefung zur
Kinderkrankenpflege überhaupt möglich
macht das heißt das Land Berlin steht
für riesen Aufgaben weil die Ausbildung
hier nicht stattfinden kann und deswegen
noch mal die gener Plastik hier ins
Plenum holen wir müssen intensiv darüber
sprechen wie die Ausbildung gerade in
der Kinderkrankenpflege aussieht und wir
müssen auch wirklich anschauen wo sind
die Ausbildungsstätten und deswegen
fordere ich ein Bonussystem in der
Ausbildung dass sie sagen wir müssen
reinschauen wo finden die Praxiseinsätze
statt und wir müssen die belohnen die
besonders attraktive Praxiseinsätze zur
Verfügung stellen und dafür werbe ich um
Zustimmung und da nehme ich sie auch
beim Wort sie haben jetzt angekündigt
zum ersten ersten im nächsten Jahr sind
Dinge scharf geschalten ich bin gespannt
denn bis heute wissen die Krankenhäuser
nicht wie die Wirtschaftspläne im
nächsten Jahr eigentlich wirklich
aussehen das ist eine riesen Aufgabe und
daran werden wir sie auch messen
und Bayern lieber Herr Kollege tut
natürlich was wir haben bei den zum
Beispiel bei den Hebammen man muss es ja
gesamtheitlich denken haben wir jetzt in
jedem Regierungsbezirk eine
Hebammenausbildung auf den Weg gebracht
ja Kinderklinik Kinderklinik ja was
glauben Sie wer im Vorraum sozusagen zur
Verfügung steht wenn der Arzt nicht da
ist dann wird bei der Hebamme angerufen
und dann wird natürlich in die
Arztpraxen gegangen und deswegen muss
man insgesamtheitlich anschauen stimmen
Sie unseren Anträgen MFA Pflegereform
alles ist aufgedröselt stimmen Sie dem
zu und unterstützen sie uns da dann
können Sie auch die Unterstützung von
uns bekommen
so weiter also das Rezept von Emmy
Zollner in der Debatte über die Krise in
den Kinderkliniken ist folgen die
Diagnosen von tatsächlich zwei Ärzten
Johannes Wagner ist Kinderarzt in Coburg
und er gehört der Fraktion Bündnis 90
die Grünen an
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen es scheint schon paradox
dass ich als Kinderarzt hier im
Bundestag stehe und darüber spreche dass
Kinderärztinnen und
kinderkrankenpflegekräfte in unserem
Kliniken fehlen wenn man sich aber
anschaut wie wenig gehört diese
Berufsgruppen in den letzten Jahren hier
in diesem Haus gefunden haben muss ich
feststellen offenbar fehlt ein
Kinderärztinnen nicht nur auf Station
sondern auch hier im Bundestag sonst
würde eine Infektionswelle nicht jedes
Mal wieder das gesamte System an den
Rand des Zusammenbruchs bringen
natürlich ist es dieses Jahr besonders
dramatisch aber Fakt ist dass
Kinderkliniken und auch niedergelassenen
Kinderärztinnen jeden Winter aufs Neue
an und über ihre Belastungsgrenzen
kommen und die Frustration darüber ist
ein gesamten gründetektor sehr sehr hoch
und zwar auf allen Ebenen das habe ich
von meinem Einzug in den Bundestag schon
persönlich gespiegelt bekommen und
erleben ist auch aktuell noch von
Kliniken von Ärztinnen und von
Pflegekräften wir haben es in
Deutschland geschafft
wunderschöne Berufe im Gesundheitssystem
zu extrem anstrengenden Berufen werden
zu lassen
vor kurzem war ich zum Beispiel bei der
Veranstaltung des Berufsverband für
Kinder und jugendärztin Bayern was
bedeutet knapp 100 aufgebrachten
Kinderärzten also alles an Kritik
entgegengebracht haben kann ich in der
Kürze der Zeit hier gar nicht vortragen
aber ich würde mir schon wünschen dass
gerade sie von der Union hier ist auch
einmal anhören würden und auch mal
mitbekommen würden wie dort über die
letzten 16 Jahre gesprochen wird denn
sie haben es nicht geschafft viele
Reformen anzugehen
wir sind aber nicht in der Tatsache dass
wir jetzt alle gemeinsam diesen
Vertrauensverlust wieder gut machen
müssen nachdem in den letzten Jahren
eher kosmetische Veränderungen
vorgenommen haben ist es endlich Zeit
das System grundsätzlich zu ändern denn
so kann es nicht weitergehen
warum machen sie es damit mit denen in
den letzten Woche
vorgestellten Vorschlägen für die eine
krankenhausreform sind wir erste
Schritte gegangen und natürlich gibt es
vor jeder großen Reform Bedenken und
Kritik aber ich möchte Ihnen sagen ich
bin tief davon überzeugt dass wir mit
dieser Reform genau die richtigen
Schritte gehen wir müssen weg von einer
reinen leistungsabhängigen Vergütung
Gesundheitsversorgung ist eine
Daseinsvorsorge wir müssen ja auch die
Vorhaltekosten mitfinanzieren und das
ist insbesondere so
das ist
insbesondere in der Kinder- und
Jugendmedizin so wo wir besonders viel
Personal und Zeit brauchen für die
Kleinen Patientinnen
es ist aber auch klar dass wir nicht von
heute auf morgen Dinge korrigieren
können die jahrelang falsch gemacht
wurden deswegen haben wir vor zwei
Wochen auch kurzfristige übergangshilfen
beschlossen und werden unter anderem die
Kinderkliniken für die nächsten beiden
Jahre mit 600 Millionen Euro zusätzlich
finanzieren und außerdem wir haben es
gerade gehört dass der Minister
angekündigt hat werden wir auch die
Niedergelassenen Kinderärztinnen und
Kinderärztinnen kommen und dort die
betätigen Grenzen auflösen
leider ist es aber auch klar dass auch
diese Maßnahmen nicht schon morgen für
mehr freie Betten in den Kinderstationen
sorgen werden so schnell geht das nicht
und deswegen ist es weiterhin wichtig
Infektionsketten zu unterbrechen als vor
zwei Jahren die Erwachsenenstation voll
waren haben wir weitreichende Maßnahmen
gemacht teilweise auch unnötige
Maßnahmen sogar Spielplätze geschlossen
jetzt sind die Kinderkliniken voll und
für manche sind selbst zu viel im ÖPNV
wo sie auf fremde Menschen treffen eine
Maske zu tragen das finde ich unser
solidarisch
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen das
Gesundheitssystem braucht dringend
Reformen und wir gehen diese an
lassen sie mich zum Schluss noch eine
weitere Sache sagen
kein Gesundheitssystem der Welt und sei
jetzt noch so gut kann mit den
Gesundheitsgefahren einer eskalierenden
Klimakrise umgehen deswegen ist
Klimaschutz auch vorausschauende
Gesundheitspolitik vielen Dank
Johannes Wagner Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen mit seiner Diagnose als Kinder
und jugendarzt bzw Kinderarzt Kinder und
jugendärztin ist die nächste Rednerin
Leser hatte baradari aus der
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin der
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren eins
vorneweg als Berichterstatterin meiner
Fraktion für Kinder und jugendgesundheit
und auch als praktizierende Fachärztin
für Kinder und Jugendliche möchte ich
der Opposition dafür danken dass sie der
schwierigen Lage der Kinderkliniken in
Deutschland mit dieser aktuellen Stunde
noch einmal die dringend notwendige
Aufmerksamkeit verschafft es ist aber
natürlich nicht so als wäre dies den
Regierungsfraktionen nicht schon längst
bekannt die aktuelle Welle an SV
Infektion und anderen grippalen
Virusinfektion werfen ein schlaglich auf
einen Sektor der schon lange
unterfinanziert und unterbesetzt ist und
der besonders unter den
Fehlentwicklungen sowohl im ambulanten
als auch im stationären pädiatischen
Bereich gelitten hat bereits im
krankenhauspflege entlassungsgesetz
haben wir deshalb Maßnahmen ergriffen
das wurde schon oftmals hier erwähnt um
den Kinderkliniken und Geburtsstation
kurzfristig Hilfen zur Verfügung zu
stellen für die nächsten zwei Jahre
werden wir insgesamt
840 Millionen Euro für deren
Finanzierung zur Verfügung stellen und
wir führen die PPR 2.0 Pädiatrie plus
intensiv ein diese kurzfristigen Reform
haben wir bereits auf dem Weg gebracht
drei Jahre und die langfristigen Pläne
die künftig Notlagen wie die aktuelle
verhindern werden sind längst in Arbeit
letzte Woche stellt ihr die
Regierungskommission ihre dritte
Stellungsnahme und Empfehlung für eine
grundlegende und moderne
krankenhausreform vor die Vorschläge
beinhalten eine bedarfsgerechte
Krankenhausversorgung mit
vorhaltepauschalen in Höhe von 60
Prozent für die Pädiatrie auch durch das
wurde schon hier genannt die Herausnahme
der pflegebudgets und reformierte die
also reformierte Fallpauschalen ich
begrüße diese Vorschläge aber wer glaubt
allein allein durch eine sofortige
Abschaffung der Fall pauschalen würden
plötzlich paradiesische Zustände in die
deutschen Krankenhäuser und
Kinderkliniken einkehren der wird
gewaltig inzwischen sind wohl viele zu
jung um sich noch an die damals durchaus
guten Gründe für die Einführung der
Fallpauschalen zu erinnern die 80er und
90er Jahre Mann mit nichten die goldenen
Zeiten der stationären Versorgung mit
den Reformplänen wollen wir die leider
entstandenen Fehlanreize die im
aktuellen System der Fallpauschalen
enthalten sind abbauen und somit die
Fehlentwicklung der letzten 20 Jahre
korrigieren wir wollen aber nicht
einfach die Uhr zurückdrehen und mit der
Gießkanne Geld über Deutschland
ausschütten auch die Fachgesellschaften
auch die Fachgesellschaften aus dem
Bereich Kinder und Jugendmedizin und mit
denen rede ich wirklich sehr oft betonen
immer wieder es muss nicht um Quantität
sondern um Qualität gehen denn nicht
geringeres verdienen unsere Kinder
da dürfen darf man auch durchaus mal
applaudieren wir müssen den
Fachkräftemangel angehen auch wegen der
demokratischen Herausforderung die
massiv auf uns zukommen es gibt jetzt
schon beispielsweise in
Berlin-Brandenburg 15 Prozent weniger
kinderkrankenpflegefachpersonal als
benötigt würde und dieser Trend wird
sich durch Renteneintritt der
Babyboomer-Generation weiter verstärken
wohlgemerkt bei einem gleichzeitigen
Anstieg der Geburt in den vergangenen
zehn Jahren die Länder stehen hier
genauso in der Pflicht sie müssen mehr
Medizinstudium Plätze anbieten überhaupt
Ausbildungsplätze für
Kinderkrankenpflege zur Verfügung
stellen und ihren Part bei der
krankenhausreform und den
Investitionskosten übernehmen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Krankheitsbilder der Kinder sind
komplexer geworden und die Pädiatrie hat
sowohl bei der großen Anzahl der
geflüchteten in den Jahren 2015 und
danach und jetzt auch in der Ukraine ihr
Bestes getan um viele Kinder gut zu
versorgen in den niedergelassenen
Arztpraxen und in den Kliniken daher
möchte ich auch an dieser Stelle meinen
besonderen Dank an alle Beschäftigten in
der Pädiatrie Richtung insbesondere an
kinderkrankenpflegerinnen und Pfleger
eine medizinischen Fachangestellten an
die Kinderärztinnen und Ärzte in unserem
Land abschließend kann man sagen gut
dass wir dieses wichtige Thema endlich
ins Plenum tragen und darüber
debattieren wir sind uns als Koalition
aber bewusst wir lassen keine
politischen schnellschlüssel los sondern
verfolgen akribisch unsere Ziele die
Stärkung der Pflege die ambulantisierung
und eine Finanzierung die sich am Bedarf
und Qualität orientiert wir lassen kein
Kind zurück vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit die Kinder und jugendärztin nesa
hat baradari außer der SPD-Fraktion in
einer Debatte über die Krise in den
Kinderkliniken und eine Ärztin haben wir
noch für Sie bei den letzten drei
Rednerinnen jetzt erstmal Erich
irrelsdorfer aus der Unionsfraktion erst
Mitglied im Gesundheitsausschuss
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
ich merkte auf einmal die große Liebe
für die Kinder und Jugendmedizin schön
sehr gut das freut mich und ich kann
Ihnen nur ein Song
ein bisschen auf Vertrauen in unserem
Minister sollen wir auf jeden Fall schon
einmal
hier ist eine klare Ankündigung gemacht
worden dass man hier kurzfristig für
zwei Jahre mit 300 Millionen pro Jahr
hier das Thema schauen und dergleichen
und auch die Vorhaltekosten und alles
bezahlen wird dieses generell richtig
das ist notwendig überfällig und deshalb
werden wir das jetzt machen und ich
glaube dass wir dieses Union auch
unterstützen genauso richtig finde ich
aber auch dass hier von der Linken
dieses Thema ins Plenum zurückgebracht
wird deshalb diskutieren wir es hier und
ich kann Ihnen nur eins sagen meine
Kollegin Zöllner oder das hat so vorher
schon angesprochen und ich war bei
diesem Gespräch mit dabei bitte erlauben
Sie mir diese ausführende stört mich
dass ich hier Leute hier vorne
hinstellen und zu tun wir werden sie die
letzten Jahre nicht dabei gewesen wir
waren in der großen Koalition dort
gesessen wir haben das Thema
generalistische Ausbildung diskutiert
und es war eine klare Haltung der Union
dass wir gesagt haben wir wollen hier
einen funktionierenden Beruf nicht in
die generalistik implementieren weil wir
der Meinung sind das läuft und es waren
damals für die Kinder und Jugendpflege
hatten wir neuen Bewerbungen für eine
Stelle heute bringen wir die Stellen
nicht bevor und jetzt sich hinzustellen
und so zu tun wie die SPD sich dann
schlanken Fuß macht kann ich nur sagen
diese inhaltlich falsch und das ist
verlogen meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
so und da wir auch einen Teil von diesem
Fehler sind weil wir uns nicht
durchsetzen konnten kann ich nur sagen
dass wir endlich hier dieses Thema
generalistische Ausbildung und somit
auch die Herauslösung wieder von der
Kinder- und Jugendpflege ins Parlament
holen wollen man kann einen Fehler
machen aber wenn man sieht dass es
falsch ist und das ist ein Fehler ist
muss man es korrigieren und das ist
meine herzliche Bitte
ich interessiere mich nicht ob das die
Länder wollen wir hier Herrinnen
entscheiden und das Richtige tun und ich
kann Ihnen nur sagen nein nein ich kann
Ihnen nur sagen dass eigentliche Problem
ist nicht die hohe Anzahl der kranken
Kinder sondern das eklatanti Problem ist
der Mangel an Personal und deshalb
müssen wir betten sperren deshalb können
wir die Kinder nicht versorgen und dass
dies natürlich in so einer Situation
ankommt und dass die Eltern Angst um das
ist doch vollkommen normal wir müssen
praxisnah Handeln meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren und das ist notwendig
und
ich möchte auch noch etwas anbringen
dass wir auch beim Thema Geburt dieses
Wissen dass wir hier generieren könnten
und wir haben ja die ganzen
Untersuchungen und alles was dazugehört
ich stelle mir schon die Frage warum wir
in Deutschland die Situation haben dass
wir einfach hier bei der ersten
Untersuchung und in diesem ganzen langen
Prozess an die 30 Krankheiten abklären
können andere Länder teilweise 70 und an
und 80 Krankheiten um die Asien z.B aus
dem Abfallprodukt eine Geburt der
Nabelschnur Wissen generiert wird von
teilweise 1000 bis 1200 Erkrankungen
warum machen wir das nicht und dann
heißt es immer wieder ja das ist der
Datenschutz ich bin ein Fan von
Datenschutz aber wenn der Datenschutz
bessere Versorgung verhindert dann ist
das nicht in Ordnung meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren und da müssen wir ran
und ich glaube auch dass diese Reform
dass uns die schon nach vorne bringen
kann und ich glaube auch dass wir es
Union und das ist ein Angebot Herr
Minister dass wir hier bereits sind
mitzuarbeiten und dafür bereit sind
unsere Dinge auch dementsprechend so zu
formulieren dass wir hier wieder eine
Stabilität reinbekommen das ist doch
notwendig um mich hier höre ja die
Länder wollen und die Länder da kann ich
nur sagen es muss ein Zusammenarbeiten
zwischen Bund und Land sein und wir
werden diese Situation nur verbessern
wenn wir hergehen und wenn wir das
gemeinsam machen letzter Punkt damit man
auch ein Beispiel hat bei der
Blutabnahme bei einem Erwachsenen da das
ganze ein paar Minuten hier kommt eine
Fachkraft her macht es und alles ist gut
bei dem Kind braucht man halt einfach
länger und deshalb ist es natürlich so
das häufig auch ein Elternteil dabei ist
dass das Kind Angst hat dass scheint und
da dauert es vielleicht auch eine Zeit
von 20 Minuten oder eine halbe Stunde
tatsache ist aber dass man bei der
Abrechnung hier keinen Cent mehr bekommt
und deshalb muss man das Thema der
Fallpauschalen schon natürlich
diskutieren und diese Diskussion müssen
wir anfangen und dann müssen wir schauen
dass wir hier nicht einfach tabula Raser
machen sondern fallpauschal
bringen nein man muss klug handeln man
muss vielleicht auch ein Mischsystem
machen und wir müssen hier ins gelingen
verliebt sein herzlichen Dank
Erich irlstorfer aus der Unionsfraktion
3 zerredner in dieser Debatte und jetzt
kommt Nicole Westig aus der FDP-Fraktion
und sie ist pflegepolitische Sprecherin
dort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
laut RKI leidet fast jeder zehnte
hierzulande aktuell an einer
Atemwegserkrankung beinahe 9 Millionen
Menschen besonders betroffen sind
Schulkinder zwischen fünf und 14 Jahren
Säuglinge und Kleinkinder leiden unter
dem er erst Virus viele mit schweren
verläuften das führt zu alarmierende
Nachrichten aus unseren Kinderkliniken
viele haben keine freien Betten mehr zu
oft müssen schwere schwerkranke Kinder
in weit entfernte Kliniken gebracht
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
das ist eine Entwicklung die uns alle
entsetzt gleichwohl kommt sie nicht
überraschend das Kinder sich nach
maskenpflicht und lockdowns nun vermehrt
infizieren und Atemwegserkrankungen
regelrecht nachholen war zu erwarten das
völlig unabhängig davon die
Kinderkliniken und Kinderstationen in
unserem Land große Schwierigkeiten haben
war seit langem bekannt
trotzdem hat es über viele Jahre hinweg
keine gesetzgeberische Initiative
gegeben um hier entgegenzuwirken
die ampelregierung war sich schnell
einig an dieser Situation etwas zu
ändern in der Pädiatrie kurzfristig für
eine auskömmliche Finanzierung zu sorgen
haben wir in unserem Koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten
mit dem gerade
verabschiedeten krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz sind wir den ersten
Schritt in diese Richtung gegangen und
unterstützen die Kinderkliniken mit
jeweils 300 Millionen Euro in den
nächsten zwei Jahren
klar kommt dieser Schritt für diesen
Winter zu spät doch er ist getan und die
Kinderkliniken wissen das sehr zu
schätzen durch die extrem heterogene
Patientengruppe haben Kinderkliniken in
enorme Vorhaltekosten sie müssen
gleichermaßen vorbereitet sein auf das
300 Gramm leichte Frühgeborene wie auf
den Übergewichtigen Teenager diese
Kosten lassen sich durch die
Fallpauschalen nicht abdecken und
deshalb entlasten wir hier und schon
bald werden weitere Schritte folgen wir
müssen dahin kommen die
Versorgungsstruktur aus Sicht der
Familien zu denken auch deshalb werden
wir die Richtung hin zu mehr
ambulantisierung einschlagen Menschen
werden zu Hause am besten gesund und das
gilt insbesondere für Kinder wir würden
kein Kind länger als notwendig bei uns
lassen denn das macht kein Elternteil
mit höre ich dazu aus der Kinderklinik
Sankt Augustin kein Wahlkreis wenn die
Kinder jedoch stationär bleiben müssen
dann sind heutzutage die Eltern bei
Ihnen und darauf sind viele
Kinderkliniken baulich nicht
ausgerichtet zu kleine Zimmer verkommene
Bausubstanz liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir brauchen eine
investitionsoffensive für unsere
Kinderkliniken der Bund geht den ersten
Schritt mit der dringend notwendigen
finanziellen Unterstützung bei den
Vorhaltekosten weitere müssen folgen
aber da sind auch die Länder gefragt sie
müssen nachholen was sie in den
vergangenen Jahren an Investitionen
versäumt haben
doch selbst wenn wir künftig finanziell
besser ausstatten und auch endlich mehr
investieren stehen wir weiterhin vor
einem Problem denn meine Damen und
Herren Betten pflegen keine Patienten
und auch in unseren Kinderkliniken
herrscht akuter Personalmangel fast 40
Prozent der Kinder Intensivbetten können
laut die wie deshalb nicht betrieben
werden deshalb müssen wir auch noch
einmal auf die Pflegeausbildung schauen
ja aber nicht das Rad zurückdrehen
aktuell gibt es nicht genug
Ausbildungsplätze mit dem
vertiefungsschwerpunkt Pädiatrie hier
sollten wir Anreize setzen damit die
Träger sich ihrer Verantwortung bewusst
werden und mehr anbieten wir brauchen
tragfähige Einarbeitungskonzepte für die
erforderliche Spezialisierung nach der
generalistischen Ausbildung hierfür
müssen wir uns jetzt auf den Weg machen
und für einen nahtloses
Weiterbildungskonzept sorgen hierzu
wünsche ich mir schnell entsprechende
bundländergespräche
einige Kommunen gehen schon mit gutem
Beispiel voran zum Beispiel kooperieren
in der Stadt Dortmund die Pflegeschulen
bei der Einsatzplanung
trägerübergreifend um allen
Auszubildenden sinnvolle pädiatrische
Einsätze zu ermöglichen teilweise auch
mit pädiatrischer Vertiefung ein
Modellprojekt der Akademie der
münchen-klinik GmbH wird mit einem
Konzept für kurze aber intensive
pädiatrische Einsätze der hohen Anzahl
an benötigten Plätzen gerecht das kann
sicher als Best Practice Beispiel dienen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sehen
wie komplex die Schwierigkeiten für
unsere Kinderkliniken sind die bloße
Forderung nach einer Abschaffung der
faltpauschalen wird dem in keinster
Weise gerecht und macht keinen Sinn
Unterstützung bei den vorhaltestelle
investitionsoffensive durch die Länder
und Sicherung der Vertiefung für die
Krankenpflege Ausbildung meine Damen und
Herren im Namen von uns allen möchte ich
allen die aktuell und vor allem in den
nächsten Weihnachtsfeiertagen unser
System der Gesundheit am Laufen halten
Nicole westlich war das aus der
FDP-Fraktion in der gleichenden Debatte
über die Krise in den Kinderkliniken der
ist das Interesse der Fraktion wenn man
sich hier mal so umschaut
unterschiedlich groß bei diesem Thema
wir kommen zur letzten Rednerin das noch
mal eine Ärztin Tina Rudolf aus der
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist schon
spannend für welche Bandbreite an Themen
man so eine Aktuelle Stunde benutzen
kann angefangen von mal wieder
unverhohlener unsachgemäßer und
unwissenschaftlicher Kritik an
corona-impfungen und Schutzmaßnahmen bis
zu sorry am letzten Aufgebot dessen dass
einem die Fälle wegschwimmen weil sich
eine langjährige politische Forderung
gerade vor ihren Augen durch
Regierungshandeln erledigt
zum ersten Punkt
Liebe Fraktion Rechtsaußen fühlen Sie
sich davon bitte nicht zu sehr
angesprochen nicht für sie aber
vielleicht für diejenigen die zuschauen
und die vielleicht auch verunsichert
sind für das was teilweise gerade in den
Medien steht dass wir eine besonders
große Welle von von Grippe oder auch von
RSV gerade vor uns haben die mit Corona
Impfungen irgendwie zusammenhängen
könnte oder dass die maskenpflicht jetzt
dazu führt dass Grippewellen und erst VW
nachgeholt werden also auf der einen
Seite ist es so dass wir bei den
genannten Erkrankungen sowohl Grippe da
sind diese Songs 2016/17 zu nennen aber
auch 2017 und 18 und beim ersten Virus
ist es leider immer so der Kollege
Wagner hat das ja auch ausgeführt die
Kinderkliniken sind da jedes Jahr in
einer sehr sehr angespannten Situation
also hier die Korrelation darzustellen
dass ich das an den corona-impfungen
aufziehen würde oder auch an die Masken
das ist einfach viel zu kurz gegriffen
und sachlich falsch was sein kann ist
dass es in diesem Jahr eine Menge
erstauffällen gibt auch deshalb weil es
im letzten Jahr eine maskenpflicht gab
aber auch hier ist zu sagen dass es für
Kinder insgesamt gut ist war das
rsv-virus gerade im ersten Jahr den
verheerendsten Schaden anrichten kann
und den schlimmsten Krankheitsverlauf zu
erfahren lässt deswegen auch hier gut
selbst wenn es sich um nachgeholte
Krankheitsfälle handelt das eben eine
Infektion nicht eher da ist also bitte
hören Sie auf solche Sachen zu
verbreiten dass man das Immunsystem nur
einfach mit irgendwas konfrontieren muss
und dann wird das Ganze schon das war
mir ein Bedürfnis nochmal zu sagen weil
ich glaube dass wir uns um
Wissenschaftlichkeit und auch ein
Richtigstellung hier in solchen Fragen
bemühen müssen aber jetzt auch wieder
zum eigentlichen Thema nämlich zudem
dass die die es abgeschafft werden
sollen dass wir das privat der
Fallpauschalen im Gesundheitswesen
natürlich überwinden müssen aber der
Aufhänger Liebe Linksfraktion ist ja die
aktuelle Situation und ich glaube wer
weiß wie gerade die Situation in den
Kinderkliniken ist wer die Berichte im
Fernsehen dazu sieht wer mit ärztlichen
oder pflegerischen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen redet niemand lässt das kalt
und es ist auch nicht so dass wir eine
solche Situation zum ersten Mal haben
sondern es ist seit Jahren leider so
dass in Kinderkliniken meistens im
Herbst eine sehr sehr prekäre Situation
herrscht und dass wir wissen und gesehen
haben dass gerade das System der
Fallpauschalen auch dazu geführt hat
dass gerade auf den Kinderkliniken in
den letzten Jahren eine Norma Kosten
drucklagt unter anderem auch daran zu
sehen dass wir immer weniger
Kinderkliniken haben und viele eben noch
geschlossen haben das heißt hier ist
dringend Handeln erforderlich was
allerdings nicht geht ist es überhaupt
nicht wenn wir uns heute darauf einigen
würden oder auch wenn wir einem dieser
Anträge zugestimmt hätten dass die
System abzuschaffen in Klammern die
Frage und was dann dass ich dann die
Situation schlagartig verbessern wird
sondern dass die Situation ummittelbar
verbessert aber auch da darf man nicht
erwarten dass das morgen passiert ist
dass wir die Kinderkliniken finanziell
entlasten was wir schon ab Beginn des
nächsten Jahres tun werden was für
politische Prozesse ein sehr sehr
schneller Zeit
ist und dass wir jetzt akut kurzfristig
natürlich auch Dinge tun wie das man
versucht Personal auf andere Stationen
umzuschichten was eben sein muss und wir
wissen dass wir damit viel abverlangen
und wir wissen dass es gerade für das
Personal schwierig ist nachdem wir von
einer corona-welle in die nächste und
jetzt eben auch in die rsv-welle
gekommen sind und trotzdem diese
Regierung ist es die das Problem sowohl
kurzfristig durch eine finanzielle
Besserstellung der Kinderkliniken aber
eben auch langfristig durch die
Überwindung des privat der
Fallpauschalen angeht es ist diese
Regierung es ist dieser
Gesundheitsminister der die Mut hat
einen Berliner Vorschlag dafür
vorzubringen und das ist das erste Mal
seit Jahren dass das passiert nicht nur
die Forderung zu äußern die
Fallpauschalen abzuschaffen sondern
einen wirklichen gegen
Finanzierungsvorschlag zu machen und zu
wissen wo wir damit nämlich eigentlich
hin wollen und das Ganze in eine große
Reform des Gesundheitswesens zu gießen
deswegen ich danke Ihnen Herr Minister
dass sie den Mut haben die
Regierungskommission eingesetzt zu haben
die schon nach einem Jahr enorm gute von
viele Vorschläge vorgelegt hat bei denen
die wenn die Umsetzung gehen und ich
danke Ihnen dass Sie den Mut haben eine
große krankenhausreform anzustreben und
ich danke Ihnen auch jetzt schon für die
Beharrlichkeit die das ganze erfordern
wird denn es ist kein leichtes
Unterfangen das sind tiefgreifende
Strukturreformen die wir anstreben vom
Primat der Fallpauschalen zu eine
größere Finanzierung der Vorhaltekosten
zu kommen zu einer besseren
strukturfinanzierung aber auch zu
generellen Struktur Umbrüchen nämlich
indem wir Kliniken in Versorgungsstufen
unterteilen werden zu kommen all das
wird Mut und Tatkraft erfordern aber
wenn es einfach wäre könnte das jeder
wir müssen in dieser Legislatur damit
anfangen wir müssen es schaffen dass wir
das Gesundheitssystem gut und
zukunftsfähig aufstellen deswegen Herr
Minister dabei haben sie unsere volle
Unterstützung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lassen Sie uns diese Form
angehen vielen Dank Tina Rudolf ist
Ärztin ist Mitglied der SPD-Fraktion und
war die letzte Rednerin in dieser
aktuellen Stunde die auf Antrag der
Linksfraktion stattgefunden hat das ging
um die Krise in den Kinderkliniken es
wird nicht die letzte Debatte
zu diesem Thema im Bundestag gewesen
sein denn das Problem wir wissen es alle
ist dringlich